[Musique]
le quartier de mieux le Nord Parker au
nord de Copenhague souffre d'une
mauvaise réputation la loi danoise le
considère officiellement comme une
société parallèle un label qui heurte
les habitants du quartier comme Saïd un
jeune étudiant en architecture
lorsque l'on grandit ici que l'on voit
comment le gouvernement implique ses
lois qui vit seulement une partie de la
société
et bien forcément on a un sentiment
d'injustice
depuis 2018 les autorités danoises ont
établies des critères qui définissent
ces sociétés parallèles communément
appelées ghetto parmi lesquels un taux
de chômage au-delà de 40%, un taux de
criminalité plus élevé que la moyenne
nationale et surtout un taux d'habitants
d'origine non occidentale qui dépasse
les 50%
, ces critères autorisent leur
démantèlement ici de bâtiments ont été
rasés et les deux tiers de ces logements
sociaux vont devenir privés
voici une vue aérienne de mieux parken
après les rénovations en cours sur le
terrain la régie immobilière est chargée
de mettre en oeuvre la politique du
gouvernement une méthode agressive mais
justifiée selon le responsable du
quartier
en 2017 nous avons eu une guerre de gang
à Copenhague avant ça en 2015 il y a eu
des fusillades terroristes liés d'une
certaine manière à mieux le parken
tout cela nous a ramené des années en
arrière et a eu raison de la patience
des responsables politiques
250 familles ont déjà déménagé elles
sont pour la plupart relogées dans des
quartiers plus excentrés
mais de nombreux résidents comme Michael
Feller refusent de quitter la cité
je l'aime beaucoup ce quartier les gens
sont très gentils ici on sent que l'on
peut parler à tout le monde
est enseignante elle habite depuis 8 ans
à mieux Nord Parker avec d'autres
habitants du quartier elle porte plainte
contre le gouvernement danois pour ce
qu'elle considère comme une politique
discriminatoire les plaignants sont
soutenus par un rapport des Nations
Unies
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
danoise que les Nations Unies
s'associent à une plainte contre le
gouvernement
bien sûr cette loi est également
discriminatoire envers les personnes qui
ont des bas salaires
ou un faible niveau d'éducation
mais le critère essentiel est
déterminant c'est le critère des
origines non occidental
et c'est cela que nous dénonçons avec
cette plainte
à Copenhague deux quartiers sont
actuellement considérés comme des
sociétés parallèles à démonter ici à
timbiya la municipalité a libéré des
terrains pour la construction de
logements privés une maison individuelle
écoute environ 300000 euros un prix
inaccessible pour les habitants du
quartier
vous voyez ce sont surtout les
soi-disant vrai danois qui vivent ici
Leila a grandi dans cette cité qu'elle
peine désormais à reconnaître la jeune
étudiante est de nationalité danoise
d'origine tunisienne et palestinienne
avec la loi anti-ghetto la
stigmatisation des populations immigrées
c'est aggravées selon elle
d'abord mon prénom n'est pas danois mon
nom de famille ne l'est pas non plus et
en plus j'ai cette adresse
et c'est très compliqué de trouver un
travail avec tout ça
reste que la politique d'intégration au
forceps menée par le gouvernement
social-démocrate et soutenu par la
majorité des autres partis politiques le
maire de Copenhague en charge de
l'intégration en vente les résultats
la criminalité est en baisse et on
constate également que de nombreux
habitants de ces quartiers ont un
travail normal désormais le taux de
chômage a baissé de 30% dans le secteur
ça va dans la bonne direction
au Danemark la crise migratoire de 2015
en particulier a marqué un tournant
cette année-là le pays a accueilli plus
de 75 000 personnes contre une moyenne
annuelle autour de 50 000 depuis 2010 un
record qui a relancé le débat sur
l'immigration et l'intégration
et candidat dans la circonscription de
miel Nord parken il représente un
nouveau parti vert et antiraciste pour
lui les lois anti ghetto sont surtout
destinés à envoyer un signal à tous les
migrants
depuis 20 ans les gouvernements
successifs se livrent à une compétition
sur les politiques d'immigration
il s'agit d'envoyer un message au
réfugiés et aux migrants pour qu'ils ne
viennent pas au Danemark
au fil du temps toutes les politiques
ont ainsi viré à droite et aujourd'hui
nous avons les lois les plus strictes en
la matière
les autorités veulent éradiquer toutes
les cités considérées comme des ghettos
d'ici à 2030 une vingtaine de quartiers
se trouvent actuellement sur la liste
officielle des sociétés parallèles